foreign
they'll use drugs right here and it's I
mean several of my videos have been
taken right here you know right here on
the Federal Building uh property and
these security guards they feel helpless
because they can't really enforce
anything because they've literally been
told to stand down
foreign
man you got kids walking out here man
that woman just had to run out of here
this area because there's so much drug
use and our children
are not safe her kid's not safe around
here
uh name's Richie Wynn um I'm a San
Francisco resident been a native here my
whole life a former incarcerated convict
uh extra drug addict and now I'm doing a
little activism a little uh Street
journalism if you will down here in San
Francisco documenting uh the
humanitarian crisis and the fentanyl
frenzy that we have here in San
Francisco California really they should
restart rethinking their policies here
because this harm reduction site it just
doesn't work they need absent-based
treatment they need to get clean they
need help to get back on the road to
recovery they don't need more syringes
they don't need crack pipes they don't
need tin foil they don't need any of
that they need to get some recovery in
their life
right now the season approaches um this
harm reduction model which is kind of a
failed model they should really abandon
it in my opinion is really doing more um
harm than it is doing good uh it
basically allows these addicts to keep
living in a state of bondage to where
they are just receiving free money from
the government or whether it's you know
unemployment or general assistance and
they live in these tents they steal
things from the the supermarkets or the
clothing stores or whatever then they
sell it to these people out here and for
money for drugs there's no it's like a
lawless night a lawlessness type of
situation where there's no consequences
for their actions and they just continue
to be able to live in in this in this
way now the city has tried to implement
something called a safe consumption site
they're trying to push for this right
now I'm really against these sites
because you have to ask yourself the
question what happens when the funding
for these safe consumption sites run out
just like they ran out for the
navigation centers that were ran by five
Keys here in San Francisco basically
what happens is these people still get
put out on the streets but with no
treatment and no type of
recovery based uh approach and so they
basically are going to stay in this this
cycle of using and stealing and breaking
the law which makes it harder for the
other
side of San Francisco the the citizens
the tax paying citizens the hard-working
people to really coexist here it makes
it really hard and that's why you kind
of have like a mass Exodus from
California right now it's kind of sad
you have to combat the problem where it
begins and that happens with arresting
the drug dealers changing some of the
sanctuary laws to actually get some of
these individuals that are breaking the
law out of San Francisco or out of the
country really and and have them stop uh
attacking or or poaching on these uh
mentally ill American citizens that are
here that are struggling with addiction
and other things you know because that's
what's happening